Trascrizione: Giulia Vecchi
Revisore: Piero Cavallo
La mia prima gastrite da incazzatura
l’ho avuta nel 2008
quando non sapevo niente di diritti,
politica, parità.
Io sono di Napoli e nel 2008 a Napoli,
vicino a Napoli, a Castelvolturno,
successe una cosa.
130 proiettili esplosero da un’auto
e uccisero sette persone.
Sei di queste persone erano
dei ragazzi giovanissimi,
provenienti da varie parti dell’Africa.
A Castelvolturno ci furono delle proteste
e si iniziò a dire che queste persone
erano state uccise in quanto coinvolte
con la camorra, in quanto immigrati.
Falso.
Ci furono proteste ancora più forti,
soprattutto da parte della comunità
africana di Castelvolturno.
Si rovesciarono delle auto,
si ruppero delle vetrine.
Io avevo 15 anni e mi ricordo
distintamente che si parlò di questo
omicidio atroce più o meno per 24 ore.
Dopodiché, si iniziò a parlare
solo ed esclusivamente
di queste cazzo di vetrine rotte.
Il focus passò da un omicidio atroce
a il vandalismo della comunità africana.
Si parlava non più di omicidio, ma della
rabbia spaventosa della comunità africana.
Io me lo ricordo.
E mi ricordo che ero profondamente scossa
dall’evidente errore di proporzione
nello sdegno collettivo:
vetrine rotte, omicidio.
Mi ricordo che ne stavo parlando
al telefono con una mia amica
e a un certo punto c’è un tizio
che si avvicina
con questa mano a uncino che mi fissa
e mi fa: “Ma che ti incazzi a fare?”
“Ma che ti incazzi a fare?”
La mia prima gastrite da incazzatura.
E io lì ho iniziato a riflettere sul
“che ti incazzi a fare”
e quindi io qui oggi con voi mi chiedo:
ma che cosa è più pericoloso
tra un urlo e il silenzio?
Che cosa è più pericoloso tra
l’azione e la passività?
Con tutta questa rabbia io che ci faccio?
Quando noi andiamo in giro a dire
che siamo incazzati,
quella rabbia che ci logora,
quella rabbia da “In Italia
c’è un femminicidio ogni 72 ore”,
quella rabbia da
“L’Italia non è un paese razzista”,
quella rabbia da “Io stasera
vorrei uscire, ma non posso uscire
perché non ho il passaggio e se
torno da sola è troppo pericoloso.”
quell’Italia da “L’Italia affossa
le leggi contro l’odio”, quella rabbia lì.
Se io vado in giro con quella rabbia lì,
la gente mi guarda e mi dice “Ma calmati,
perché se no passi dalla parte del torto.”
La parte del torto raga è un luogo oscuro
perché dalla parte del torto
ci fanno credere che ogni torto
sia uguale ad un altro.
Che ogni rabbia sia uguale ad un’altra.
E così che io, incazzata per
l’oppressione dilagante,
mi trovo nella stessa isola
del torto di chi opprime.
E così che chi rompe una vetrina
si trova nella stessa isola
del torto di chi ha ucciso.
Ma perché?
Wolf Bukowski la chiamava “La buona
educazione degli oppressi”.
Ed è quello che ci si aspetta da noi.
Quindi noi adesso qui oggi
dobbiamo parlare di una cosa
di cui non si parla mai,
ma di cui si dovrebbe parlare.
Il potere infinito politico della rabbia,
il potere politico della rabbia.
Se le suffragette non avessero lanciato
le pietre nelle vetrine,
io oggi non voterei.
Se le femministe degli anni ’70 non
avessero urlato, manifestato, protestato,
se avessero scelto
di silenziare la loro rabbia,
io oggi sarei costretta a sposare
un uomo che mi ha stuprata
per evitare che lui vada in carcere.
Allora com’è possibile che nonostante
la storia, nonostante tutto questo,
ci si continui ad aspettare
silenzio dagli oppressi?
C’è un’ideale collettivo molto preciso di
come dovrebbe essere la vittima perfetta.
La vittima perfetta sta zitta,
la vittima perfetta subisce.
Se non sta zitta a subire,
se subentra una dimensione di rabbia,
se subentra una dimensione di rivolta,
automaticamente non è più
una vittima perfetta,
automaticamente non ha più
il diritto di ribellarsi.
Lo vedete questo cerchio, questo circolo?
Questo circolo va interrotto, va spezzato.
E lo strumento più potente
dello status quo
è la svalutazione della rabbia.
Ma se quella rabbia, se quella rabbia
individuale, quella frustrazione,
quel senso di oppressione sociale
viene canalizzato,
è un potentissimo strumento politico.
Immaginate un giorno, una mattina
in cui tutti gli arrabbiati scelgono
di non silenziarsi più.
Immaginate un giorno in cui
tutti gli oppressi
scelgono di urlare tutte
le discriminazioni subite,
le violenze, gli abusi.
Allora lì, per chi tiene le redini
della repressione,
sarà difficilissimo continuare a dire
che tutta la comunità è esagerata.
Sarà difficilissimo continuare a negare
che non esiste oppressione.
Il motivo per cui la violenza,
anzi il motivo per cui la rabbia
continua ad essere circoscritta
ad una dimensione individuale
è che ci si rifiuta di vedere
la violenza collettiva che la provoca.
Ma nel momento in cui
questa violenza viene
collettivamente palesata,
allora la rabbia sarà legittimata.
Senza questo,
la società non si renderà conto
da sola della violenza che porta avanti.
Senza la rabbia a interrompere il flusso,
la violenza continuerà
ad essere normalizzata.
La rabbia è la miccia del cambiamento.
La rabbia è il no di chi si rifiuta
di essere zittito,
è il no di chi non vuole più adattarsi.
Ma...
Che significa arrabbiarsi?
Significa necessariamente essere violenti?
Significa necessariamente
sfociare nell’illegalità?
No.
Dovete immaginare la rabbia
come un enorme “basta”.
Dovete immaginare dei corpi che si
oppongono, resistono, manifestano, urlano.
Corpi schiacciati e sfiancati
dall’oppressione che li schiaccia a terra,
che schiaccia loro e che
schiaccia chi li circonda.
Non è detto che la non violenza
debba essere tranquilla.
La non violenza può essere incazzata.
Gandhi ha marciato
da Nuova Delhi fino a Ginevra.
Sono partiti in 78 e sono arrivati
a migliaia
e quando è stato urlato
alle guardie di sparare sulla folla,
gli ufficiali si sono rifiutati.
Questo è il potere della rabbia.
Le manifestazioni delle femministe per
il diritto d’aborto, i diritti sociali,
la parità salariale...
Non violenza, resistenza.
Un muro di persone che si oppone.
Un muro di persone che dice la verità.
Non un giorno, non una volta l'anno,
tutti i giorni.
La rabbia è potentissima.
La rabbia è un impeto
che può essere alimentato.
Io sono sempre incazzata, me lo sono
pure tatuata quanto sono incazzata.
La rabbia è la miccia del cambiamento,
la miccia che può cambiare il mondo.
La rabbia è lo specchio
del futuro che vogliamo.
Il potere da solo non indietreggia.
Il potere non indietreggia se non in
presenza di un potere più grande di lui.
Questo lo diceva Malcom X
70 anni fa e ve lo dico io oggi.
Incazzatevi.
Perché l’indifferenza
è il veleno della democrazia.
(Applausi)